you have to make a covenant you promise
that you'll never leave you know that if
you break that promise you'll be
punished for eternity
my name is synoptic Lucy and I spent
seven and a half years in a cult before
escaping I grew up in the backwoods
north of Redding California raised by a
single mother my upbringing wasn't a
religious one my mother had been
Catholic growing up and she sort of
rejected that the Catholic Church and
she was more or less a hippie as soon as
I turned 18 I moved to Michigan and I
found myself struggling trying to make
it on my own I tried going to college
and ended up dropping out so I was sort
of at a crossroads in my life around the
same time I had met my father for the
first time since I was a baby he's
thinking that the world's gonna end this
time that was 2003 and he was telling me
that the world was gonna end in 2012 and
he was saying a safe place to be would
be a community where they grow their own
food that's when I started looking
online for communities that grow their
own food
that's where everything changed after
one phone call I was on a Greyhound bus
for Missouri I got picked up by a guy
who called himself Bobby one of the
first things he said to me was we've
made a covenant to die to ourselves a
new covenant basically means promise I
knew that much like we made a promise to
died or so so I thought what is this
like a suicide pact what's he talking
about here so I was really nervous going
in the next experience that really
started to draw me in was that people
were really friendly almost too friendly
and they all came up to greet me as soon
as the fans pulled up and I got out and
everyone was hugging me and like we're
so happy that you're here and it was
relieving and kind of a little scary at
the same time so anyway they just like
put me right to work pretty much right
away I was always working alongside of
someone and they'd always be talking to
me about what they called the gospel of
the kingdom it mainly was focused on
them as a
and how they're greater than everyone
else particularly greater than
mainstream Christianity they were
constantly criticizing mainstream
Christianity and how there's so much
better like look we're living exactly
the way that says we should in the book
of Acts you know they're quoting these
Bible verses to me in Spanish see look
this is how you're supposed to live
following the Bible I have this thought
in my mind like well what if everyone
lived like this you know it'd be the
greatest thing if everyone on earth was
like this it could be peaceful everyone
would have a purpose I thought it was
great and I was like I want to find out
what happens if everyone lives like this
I want to do my part to make that happen
and so within three weeks I was baptized
so I became a member of the community
for the most part I was pretty happy
there for a while until I had suppressed
these urges that all young men have you
know in their minds all those feelings
started coming back at a certain point I
went to this man that they had appointed
as the Shepherd over me and I went to
him and I told him about these thoughts
I was having and he said that you got a
masturbate but you can't think about sex
while you're doing it you got to have
just a mechanical release is what they
called it and then the next problem I
ran into was they have what they call
the home teaching it's based on Genesis
9 Noah has three sons with them
Noah got drunk and one of his son Tom
was disrespectful vanilla so Noah cursed
Tom and said that his descendants shall
be the slaves of sins descendeth Shem
was the other son who was you know
respectful so they teach that all
shemites all descendants of Shem are are
white people so all black people are
descendants of Tom
so they teach that actually race-based
slavery was ordained by God I heard this
about a year after being there so like I
was already fully indoctrinated I don't
know I wanted everything else they said
true but it was really a struggle for me
to hear this you know my dad's black and
they they consider me to be a homo
because it's based on your father's
lineage that was a real struggle for me
another thing they tried to explain to
me was essentially by generalizing how
they felt all black people live they
said well wouldn't wouldn't they be
better off here
you know wouldn't they be better off
being humble and submitting to Yahshua
the Messiah you can't even get married
unless they say you can't and and then
they'll tell you who you can marry it's
completely up to them that your whole
life is just in their hands you know I
continued to to try my best but
eventually I came to a point where I
just I didn't believe it anymore
so the woman who's now my wife she was
living on the in the same community as
me and Missouri she gave me this little
note and you're not supposed to talk to
each other if you're single and of the
opposite sex outside of public setting I
initiated things I approached her and
she writes me this note and that's how
we got caught I don't think I would have
approached her had I not had those
doubts in my head in the first place I
had seen that she was she was struggling
to like she wanted to leave - and she
was ready to hitchhike I was like you
don't have to do that just you know we
can leave together yeah they had a
meeting they kicked us out and that
night we were on a bus for northern
Michigan we had to go live with my
stepdad on his farm we got to northern
Michigan in November of 2012 and it was
already getting cold and that winter it
was just really a harsh winter
eventually I did find a job at a local
farm in the springtime and I worked for
a few years and we had a son we named
him Terrance and eventually I went back
to college and I got a bookkeeping
certificate while my wife worked and I
got a job as an administrative assistant
in a warehouse and then my wife went
back to college and she got the same
certificate so we're doing fine now
there's a lot that I'm hoping
everyone can learn from from what I
experienced and that's why I wrote a
book about my experiences you know
there's a lot of really good things
about the community that I think we
could all learn from but they're they're
basic human principles that everyone can
do you don't have to join a cult you
know to be nice to people and to share
and you know you learn these things in
kindergarten so then we grow up and we
enter the the cruel world the brutality
of the world is what drove me into
joining a cult in the first place like
you could still be a good person you can
still be generous you don't have to give
up everything you have to do that
[Music]